[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
May 25th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
lots of people are still writing out
paper checks and that's raised the
likelihood of them being the target of
Fraud and theft OEM adedoyan from The
Wall Street Journal personal finance
team joins us to talk about ways to
reduce your chances of being at risk so
Owen how widespread is fraud and theft
regarding the use of paper checks theft
of checks mailed through the U.S Postal
Service has jumped significantly over
the past 18 months specifically after
2021. so according to the treasury
Department in 2022 Banks filed 680
000 check fraud reports that's almost
double the 350 000 fraud reports filed
in 2021. so why are people still using
paper checks making payments online is
so easy yeah for some people they just
prefer it they got into the habit of
sending paper checks specifically you
know older folks and people who are not
as tech savvy are going to be writing
those paper checks more in other cases
certain companies only collect paper
checks as pay payment especially rent
companies mortgage companies Utility
Services they're going to still be
asking for those paper checks who tends
to be the most at risk of being a fraud
victim a consumer Bank managing director
at JPMorgan Chase told me that
fraudsters don't discriminate so anyone
who writes checks can be at risk of this
type of fraud however most of the people
that are stealing the checks are not
just doing it one time and they're not
looking for a big check they're usually
looking for those incremental checks
made out to smaller amounts that the
victim might not even notice is missing
until it's too late oh so maybe check
your bank account often yes exactly it's
really important to check your bank
account constantly just to make sure
that you're up to date on what's coming
in and what's coming out how are the bad
guys getting a hold of checks and what
are they specifically doing to collect
money illegally they're stealing these
checks from those big blue USPS mailing
boxes that you see in neighborhoods and
around Schools they're also robbing the
people who deliver the mail and usually
those people will have a master key that
can open a lot of those boxes and so as
soon as they get access to that key they
can get access to all of the mail that's
in there some cases they're also
stealing apartment mailboxes as well so
they're looking in those in order to
find anything that's a check that they
can just take and in these cases they're
depositing them into their own accounts
or into fraudulent accounts that they've
created solely for the purpose of
caching these checks now the short
answer to this question might be stop
using paper checks but let's talk about
ways that Financial experts say that
people who do use paper checks can
protect themselves from fraud what steps
can people take even before filling out
a check one of those things is knowing
exactly where you're keeping your
checkbooks so a lot of people might
throw their checkbooks in a drawer
because they don't use them that much
and that is a big No-No banking experts
say you should know exactly where your
checks are in some cases you know
leaving your checkbook out and about is
almost as dangerous as leaving your
social security card out so make sure
that checkbook is in a safe place and
try as much as possible to limit the
number of checks you write but if that's
not possible then make sure that you're
checking your bank account every day
especially around the holidays like
Memorial Day and Christmas where banks
are often going to be closed if you do
limit the number of checks that you
write out to maybe rent to utilities
like you mentioned earlier are there
safe online options for making payments
say to people that you know yeah
nowadays banks are getting really
adaptable they urge customers to
consider paperless options like Zell
which is usually available through most
banks and and that's for
person-to-person transfers they also
encourage people to use cash app or
venmo any of those apps that they're the
most comfortable with are usually safer
than mailing out a paper check they also
encourage folks to make sure that
they're writing checks out to people
that they know as opposed to writing a
check to a stranger what other online
options could people consider those who
work in Banks recommend that people use
credit cards because in those cases it's
a lot easier to get that money back and
dispute that charge if there is a
fraudulent charge that's been made on a
credit card okay so back to checks for a
moment we often hear about fraudsters
washing checks what does that mean yeah
washing checks is a type of way that
fraudsters can get rid of all of the
information that's been written on the
check they usually will dip it into a
chemical like a nail polish remover that
wipes away all that ink so that they can
then rewrite you know the amount who the
recipient of the check is to and and all
that type of information oh yeah this
sounds like something out of a bank
heist movie yeah it feels that way but
people are doing it they're also doing
something called check baking and that's
a little bit more in this era where they
are kind of taking photos of signatures
of checks and they're then photoshopping
them onto you know a check that looks
pretty realistic and so if they have
your bank account you know routing
number an account number they can easily
just Photoshop and create a whole new
track so the type of ink you use on a
check could be important yep people that
work at check manufacturing companies
and people who study check fraud
recommend using a gel pen or some kind
of permanent pen and writing in blue or
black ink which is a little bit harder
to wash out what can people write on a
check to reduce the chances of fraud
experts recommend that people fill the
checkout all the way so don't leave any
spaces in your check where you know
someone could write something that you
didn't write or something that you
didn't intend to have sent they also
really recommend that people complete
the memo line you know where it says
this check is payable for and never put
the word cash in that box put any other
word any other descriptor but cash and
when you are writing out a check for a
specific amount make sure that the
dollar amount that you write matches the
written amount that you're right out as
well so you really want to take your
time when writing these checks many
people write checks when they're rushing
and banking experts really recommend not
to do that but you can take all these
precautionary measures and then you can
enter a whole new level of risk once you
pop the check in the mail right yeah
banking experts say that you really
don't want to have too many people
touching your check if possible you know
walk directly to the post office and
hand it to someone who works there to
make sure that it's in the right hands
and even better hand it directly to the
recipient if you're writing out a check
for someone's graduation give it to them
in person that's oganoyan from The Wall
Street Journal personal finance team and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you